mais hors murs du ballet le sénat comme
vous ne l'avez jamais entendue s'il est
un lieu du palais à retenir pour
désigner celui qui changea le plus
fréquemment d'attribution c'est
peut-être celui là est encore sachez
mesdames messieurs cave en 1818 de cet
endroit nous savons peu de choses
commençons tout de même tout d'abord un
vestiaire on connaît même le coût de
l'aménagement de cette portion de la
galerie est
6760 francs de l'époque comprenant
travaux de serrurerie de menuiserie de
peinture fourniture de paille à son
verger et autres baguette à battre les
habits ensuite eh bien regardez ce
plafond c'est au volume cette voûte ses
tableaux majestueux et ses fresques
retraçons des scènes bibliques cela ne
vous évoque-t-il rien une chapelle tout
à fait les oeuvres d'abel de pujol
giroud ébauche les ornent les murs
quatre animaux et les pour les quatre
grands médaillon de la voûte des scènes
de la vie de saint philippe et de saint
louis à l'intérieur des arcades des
anciennes fenêtres
cette chapelle vite alors pleinement les
sénateurs s'y marie dont un certain duke
praslin en retenez ce nom marie leurs
enfants leurs petits enfants mais
bientôt éclater la guerre franco
prussienne en 1870 qui marque la fin de
l' empire et voir l'avènement de la
troisième république pendant cinq ans la
deuxième chambre disparaît
la chapelle est désaffecté le préfet de
la seine qui disposent à l'heure des
lieux décide même d'y garder des
archives et lorsque le sénat réintègre
les murs en 1879 l'heure n'est pas à la
bigoterie les vieillards de l'apocalypse
ont beau bien se tenir sous leurs barbes
points de passage
au bout de quelques années la chapelle
est redécouverte nettoyer rénover un peu
la voici transformer en une salle de
réunion bientôt salle de projection à
vous entendez le bruit des travaux
diffusion d'un film sur la construction
du chemin de fer de brazzaville
et ensuite accélérons 1940 1944 l'armée
de l'air allemande occupe le palais du
luxembourg
1945 1971 c'est à nouveau une salle de
réunion 1971 2000 le secrétariat
collectif des sénateurs y installe ses
bureaux 2009 2013 silence ça tourne les
murs contreplaqué de la chapelle abrite
les locaux de public sénat de 2013 a
aujourd'hui ça y est nous y sommes vous
vous apprêtez à quitter la salle rené
monory nommé en hommage à un ancien
président du sénat salle de réunion
multimédia au décor entièrement
restaurée de l'ancienne chapelle doté à
l'entrée d'un petit vestiaire la boucle
est bouclée tout y est